mon café il est où mon café tard
ça va bien je vous ai mis de sucre comme
d'habitude comme d'habitude alors si
stage à écouter le stage ça va super
bien parce qu'effectivement je vous
explique qu le nouveau stagiaire de
salut les terriens enfin stagiaires
c'est là la bidouille catway thierry
pour m'embaucher dans cette entreprise
dans la conjoncture actuelle voilà alors
merci beaucoup pour l'augmentation
thierry parce que j'ai été augmenté
réévalué financièrement d'une semaine
sur l'autre ça c'est cool a maintenant
je suis l'heureux possesseur de tickets
resto d'une valeur de 4 euros 90 c'est
pas de la merde à ce qui nous fait
toujours un euro de plus à rajouter pour
la formule kebab frites plus cannes est
si chère à tirer a dit sont ici présents
montini points évoqués à la suite de la
conférence de rédaction le retour de
stéphane guillon wii qui a été très très
bien reçu par les téléspectateurs et ça
fait plaisir beaucoup de lettres d'amour
et parmi elles quelques lettres de
sympathisants de marine le pen
agrémenté d'une petite balle de revolver
l'intérieur merci au cou maintenant on
peut ouvrir une armurerie alors
[Applaudissements]
on a très beau plateau qui elle ce soir
ça fait plaisir en plus de tous les
trois un point commun vous êtes tous
juifs enfin sauf véronique et manu
bah du coup il ya que vous patrick
en tout cas véronique sanson je suis
très fier d'être à vos côtés
parce que je vous le dis voilà dans dans
notre famille on vous aime beaucoup vous
savez qu'à cause de vous mon deuxième
prénom c'est véronique
et encore j'ai eu de la chance parce que
ma soeur son deuxième prénom ses besoins
de personnes
[Applaudissements]
véronique vous avez été mariée avec
pierre palmade c'était un très très beau
mariage c'était pas mon sketch préféré
de pierre je préfère le scrabble ou le
colonel mais c'était très très beau
alors
et d'annoncer maintenant je suis ici
pour vous poser les questions trop con
que thierry n'a pas voulu opposer manu
vous allez tourner avec joey starr et
fabrice luchini alors est ce que c'est
vrai que il y en a quand tu les emmerdes
il peut mais son poing sur la gueule et
l'autre ils parlent pendant trois heures
véronique sanson votre première partie à
l'olympia ce avec votre fils christopher
stills alors du coup est ce que c'est
pour lui faire plaisir ou pour éviter de
payer une baby sitter
et dernière question
patrick timsit vous dites que vous aimez
faire rire avec ce qui fait mal du coup
j'attends avec impatience votre sketch
sur l'assaut de bonne
voie merci merci beaucoup bravo
people via mon stagiaire on retrouve ici
la semaine prochaine peut-être les
corrections de ne rien rater le in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu